[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday since
nobody reads books anymore all of us get
all of our history from wikipedia it's
convenient the problem is wikipedia is
so politicized and dishonest that on a
lot of topics certainly anything related
to partisan politics it's not even
really worth reading anymore there's
just too much lying
on the other hand there's a lot of stuff
there it's a huge site and there are
some gems remaining on wikipedia
so if you have a minute this weekend
take a look at the entry on mass
hysteria through the ages before the
authorities inevitably delete it as i'm
certain they will
and as you read the entry ask yourself
if any of this sounds familiar to you
there are lots of witch trials of course
many of them many many many of them over
many centuries there are plagues of
spontaneous dancing mass ghost sightings
fits of laughing and trembling and
babbling that seized entire towns at
once for no apparent reason it's all
there and then there are more esoteric
outbreaks of mass hysteria there's a
medieval french nun who according to the
entry quote inexplicably began to meow
like a cat leading the other nuns in the
convent to meow as well eventually all
of the nuns in the convent began meowing
together
leaving the surrounding community
astonished this did not stop until the
police threatened to whip the nuns
it's hilarious as you read it though at
the time the nuns definitely did not see
the humor in it they sincerely thought
they were cats
hysteria is like that when large groups
of people start acting totally crazy the
reference points disappear it all seems
normal no matter how nuts it is
so with that feature of human nature
which never changes with that in mind
take a look at this tape from
yesterday's hearing before the house
oversight committee
the topic was legal abortion but because
it is the year 2021 and we're all
convinced we're cats the conversation
soon turned to the newly established
scientific fact that men can get
pregnant watch this and i just wanted to
acknowledge a lot of people are being
left out of this conversation today
because as we know people get pregnant
and not just women but i hear people
over and over and over again say women
get pregnant but that's excluding people
that should be a part of this
conversation
yeah you don't want to exclude anyone
and it turns out that even in 2021 there
are people out there who are still
claiming that only women get pregnant
and they'd better stop claiming that or
else amando amanda presto just learned
this presta was a writer at the daily
wire and by the way a woman
so she tweeted this thought crime
assuming that she had biology on her
side she wrote this quote demanding
others call you by your preferred
pronouns and growing out your hair does
not make you a woman stop demeaning
womanhood
no amanda you stop demeaning pregnant
men
for her attack on the pregnant man
community twitter shut amanda presto
down
we are cats and that's all there is to
it
and that's true across the ocean in
great britain the head of the labor
party in the uk is now declared that men
too can have cervixes because of course
they can meow
a few days later a senior member of the
labor party was asked whether she agreed
that men can have cervixes she was asked
on television
watch this uncomfortable moment
is it transphobic to say only women have
a cervix good morning
a good morning nick and it's great to
talk to you
i just think that this issue has just
become so divisive and toxic and it pits
people against each other both groups
who face discrimination in society women
and trans women and i just find this
debate incredibly unhelpful and and and
unproductive to be totally honest is it
transphobic yes or no
is it is it transphobic
look
i just i don't even know how to start
answering these questions
oh come on rachel reeves shadow
commissioner whatever you are the labor
party
it's a simple question it's not a debate
do men have cervixes
but she can't bring herself to say it on
the other hand she doesn't dare note the
obvious which is that the entire
conversation is completely insane
so she breathes heavily she grumps quite
a bit and tries to move on to the next
topic
the washington post is hoping to avoid
moments of uncertainty like this so jeff
bezos's newspaper has just issued a new
style guidance to all of its reporters
here's what it says quote if we say
pregnant women we exclude those who are
transgender and non-binary which of
course is not defined
so no more pregnant women in the
washington post that's an outdated
inherently offensive category like
secretaries and housewives
and this is true in hospitals too across
the country some physicians are now
punishing subordinates who recognize
biological differences between men and
women
dr laura chong for example a pediatric
trainee at the sydney children's
hospitals network recently told the new
york times that health care workers
should not use terms like ovaries and
uterus
you can just say reproductive organs
chong said and that's an order
the problem
is that it may actually be medically
relevant whether somebody has ovaries
and a uterus reproductive organs might
not be specific enough
but honestly in 2021
when we're all cats who cares
curing disease may be important but is
it more important than not offending the
human rights campaign probably not
that's a conclusion the cdc has reached
the center just released a graphic
pointing out that quote only 31 of
pregnant people have been vaccinated
not pregnant women
pregnant people
and then there's the lancet which not
that long ago was considered a serious
medical journal the lancer just released
a cover with this headline quote
historically the anatomy and physiology
of bodies with vaginas have been
neglected
so that's the term
you thought you were a woman now you're
a according to the lancet a body with a
vagina
try to imagine a more dehumanizing
phrase and then it's probably not
possible to imagine it actually
at yesterday's house oversight hearing
gloria steinem showed up to prove that
she's still alive and still relevant
somehow
for 50 years steinem has been as she
describes it defending women in the 70s
she wrote a piece for cosmopolitan
magazine entitled if men could
menstruate
and then she was constantly reminding us
this and this is a quote if men could
get pregnant abortion would be a
sacrament
oh but now men can get pregnant
so the script has changed a little bit
here was gloria steinem who we should
note is now a cat
meowing telling us that absolutely
anybody can get pregnant and therefore
anyone can get an abortion watch what's
happening in texas is not only a local
issue or a women's issue it's a step
against democracy which allows us to
control
our own bodies and our own voices
remember when hitler was elected
and he was elected
his very first official act was to
padlock the family planning clinics and
declare
abortion a crime against the state
mussolini did exactly the same thing
because they knew that controlling
reproduction
and nationalizing women's bodies is the
first step in a controlling state an
all-controlling state
teresa gloria stein was always pretty
dumb but back when she was 35 nobody
noticed but rewriting history can't let
you do that sorry you're not wikipedia
actually adele hilter was an
enthusiastic eugenicist just like
margaret sanger who founded planned
parenthood he encouraged abortion
according to
almost everyone who studied this jeffrey
tumula for example law professor who's
written a lot about the nuremberg trials
hitler like gloria steinem supported
abortion not just
as a matter of physical autonomy but as
a way to keep women working and
contributing to the economy quote the
nazis preferred that the eastern
european workers not become pregnant so
they would not be taken out of the
workforce they took measures to identify
pregnant workers and to encourage or
pressure them into making use of the
abortion services the nazis provided
oh does that sound familiar
so once again
the goal is to reduce women to wage
slaves
it is more virtuous to work at jp morgan
than it is to be a mother that's what
they're telling you that's what ayanna
presley is telling you she complained
that abortion bans are tools of you
guessed it
white supremacy and the experts at the
hearings yesterday agreed watch
i think that it's very important for us
to understand the intersection
of racial justice policies and gender
justice policies and reproductive
justice policies
because you don't understand
why
these bans on abortion are not about
having more black and brown babies born
they want more white babies to be born
we're falling for it again rising to the
bait being literal
correcting insanity because you know
it's it's kind of hard to resist
there is no rational conversation about
anything currently underway in the
united states
we have to say just again in the
interest of fact checking that what you
just heard is the opposite of the truth
new york city is the biggest city in
america it's got 8 million people the
abortion rate in new york among
african-american mothers is roughly
three times the rate that it is for
white mothers thousands more black
babies are born in new york that are
born every year
so
shutting down the abortion clinics in
new york which no one's even proposing
but if you were to do that you would
have a lot more black babies than you
have now
we can't even get to that conversation
because we can no longer agree that only
women
have
babies now
men have babies so for 50 years they
told us men have no interest
in whether or not abortion's legal
because they can't have kids but now
they can
so we thought
it would be worth weighing in on this
according to the house oversight
committee it is all for your own good
watch
i know firsthand that abortion saves
lives for the thousands of people i've
cared for abortion is a blessing
abortion is an act of love abortion is
freedom
we need federal protection now
abortion is freedom finally someone said
it out loud what is it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else